ça grouille dans les couloirs de la cour
d'assises installation de caméras de
micros d'un écran géant pour permettre
une retransmission en direct des débats
mise en place de barrières de sécurité
et même de cabinet de toilette plusieurs
centaines de personnes sont attendues au
palais pour ce procès hors norme cette
organisation exceptionnelle a coûté plus
de 25000 euros de l'intérêt c'est de
permettre à tout public en dehors des
parties civiles qui sont convoqués et à
la presse de pouvoir assister aux débats
dans les conditions optimum donc ce qui
implique un certain nombre
d'aménagements et disposition a mis en
oeuvre pour faciliter l'organisation de
ce procès près de 200 personnes ont été
victimes corporels ou matériels et sept
personnes ont perdu la vie dont cet
incendie en novembre 2010 39 avocats
seront normalement présents pour les
parties civiles du jamais vu à la cour
d'assises de dijon
notre rôle est bien sûr d'accueillir les
victimes de les accompagner beaucoup de
victimes peut être aussi bien on sans
avocat le premier jour du procès et le
rôle de l'ordre des avocats sera d
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions ce que les victimes veulent
comprendre veulent obtenir réparation et
veulent aussi faire un travail de deuil
qui est nécessaire une cellule d'écouté
et de soutien psychologique sera mise en
place pour les victimes et leurs
familles pendant toute la durée du
procès dans une salle réservée à cet
effet une équipe de trois personnes deux
juristes une psychologue chaque jour du
3 au 20 du début à la fin de l'audience
ou même après puisque ce sera pendant
les moments d'interruption de l'audience
que le public ce public de victimes et
de partie civile aura forcément besoin
de nous deux cent mille euros ont
également été prévues pour les frais de
justice indemnisation des experts des
jurés des victimes ou encore des témoins
le procès dit du foyer adoma devrait
durer trois semaines le verdict est
attendu pour le 19 décembre prochain